[Musique]
sous le soleil du sud de l'île pousse
depuis 14 mois des plans d'un ananas
victoria chez didier roger 80 de temps
en temps à mener sur la route des mac
dont 450 mètres d'altitude les casques à
l'export donc nous ferrand parents comme
la commande juste là certains commencent
à mûrir on ne va pas c'est surtout la
parcelle genevois ramasser les arnaques
les bombes envoyées dizaine d'années a
deux qualités qui sont pour certains
destinés à l'export et notamment vente
éphémère organisée par l'antenne de
paris du département non espérant voir
pleurer comme ça
quatre autres au mieux non plus comment
que ça trop vite trouver un ampli vox a
déjà pris une coloration en vie comme en
métropole il fait froid donc ça appuie
trop mûrs et moins dans le goût de la
nature la réunion y pense c'est plus que
dana aussi c'est que bafé il fait un peu
de pub ou quoi ah oui tant que 152 sont
cassés les trophées je suis pas seul on
est à 4 5 mais bon il faut il faut faire
des allers retours après la récolte à la
main le travail est loin d'être fini
direction l'un des points de
conditionnement de la sca fruits cette
coopérative d'une soixantaine
d'agriculteurs qui a une vocation à
l'export désert c'était dans le champ
j'ai comme un vu passer un monde qu'on
les a nettoyés soufflé est maintenant
arrivé au moment du calibrage et la mise
en colis c'est une initiative qui doit
être conduit et qui peut être reconduit
en sachant que moi même je travaille
aussi sur des certaines type d'actions
dans différentes régions de france
donc j'ai par exemple la bretagne avec
une école qui chaque année me sollicite
pour récupérer défaut de la réunion pour
pouvoir faire la promotion une main
experte finalise enfin l'emballage c'est
aussi la même démarche pour lulic ananas
et à lecce aussi un pur pour ses
stations de conditionnement
donc maintenant on va les voir on va
dans le conditionnement du letchi grèce
bref un fruit très fragile
une partie on va dire de votre vendus
pendant l'éveil de femer mais le plus
gros de tous et laitiers ou d'ananas son
parti est exactement dans des grands
magasins comme grands frais qui
sont des clients très très exigeants sur
la qualité du produit
il ya un contrôle qualité le plus
exigeant mon avis de france et qui met
en valeur nos produits à travers leur
magasin terreur des dégustations des
petits événements et permettent aussi de
d'écouler nos produits à des prix
raisonnables
ces ventes éphémères sont des coups de
pouce pour notre agriculture est peut
être aussi une façon d'offrir un peu de
notre soleil au reste du monde elles
vont rêver avec ce produit
[Musique]